[Music]
this morning on the dish renowned
southern cooking expert Virginia Willis
born in Augusta Georgia
she loved her grandmother's southern
classics and when a family moved to
Louisiana fell for Cajun cooking - after
college and culinary schools in the US
and France she began a multifaceted
career as a chef cooking show producer
and prolific author of six cookbooks
including a winner of the James Beard
Award her latest secrets of the southern
table full of both recipes and southern
lore was published just this month
Virginia Willis good morning welcome to
the morning thank you so much for having
me we love this table
it's a bright and beautiful name
biscuits yes and more I think so we have
here in the middle it's a skirt steak
with grilled Vidalia onions and I'm
serving that with a romesco sauce and we
can use peanut or pecan but it's nuts
and and smoked paprika and peppers the
biscuits that you spoke of it wouldn't
be a southern cook book without biscuits
right right so these are big biscuits
and they're called cat head biscuits and
the reason they're called cat head
biscuits because there is as big as a
cat's head and then I have tomato ginger
green beans one of the things I'm
excited about with this book is that the
the recipes are a little unusual I'm
drawing two different cultures so this
has ginger and tomato and cilantro
you're about to hopefully enjoy the
raspberry lemonade and it can it can
either be adulterer or not right exactly
and then here I have a summer squash
salad and that's tossed with a lemon
harissa and peach Kate peach upside-down
cake
fantastic you mentioned the biscuits and
I want to come in there with ya and
mother yes was it about cooking when you
were young with her that just were spoke
to you it was really think the kitchen
was my favorite place to be and there
are photographs of me three years old
making biscuits with my grandmother and
I just really think that's so important
to be in the kitchen with kids you know
it teaches them history and math and
teaches so many things so that was just
always my favorite place how did you get
cooking as a profession my first job
cooking was actually on a TV cooking
show it was as an apprentice for Natalie
Dupree exactly and what did you learn
from her I always like to say that my
that Natalie took me out of my mom's
kitchen and expose me to things that I
had not been exposed to before even
though my mom was a really my mama is
still a very adventurous cook right I'm
Natalie just showed me more the classic
French technique and it was fantastic
you were also a kitchen director for
Bobby Flay from Martha Stewart Hey
when and why did you decide to then go
out on your own so I really reached a
point where I was making recipes for
other people and I wanted to start
making my own recipes and that's when my
first book came out I'm 10 years ago
actually called Bon Appetit y'all and
it's recipes and stories from three
generations of southern cooking you have
resisted the idea of opening a
restaurant which works the direction a
lot of chefs obviously why did why then
well it's you know there's so many
different aspects of the culinary field
I often laugh at I might do it backwards
and when I'm ready to retire of course I
take a bite of the biscuit before I'm
sorry they're resist the stories you
mention in the cookbook it's it's not
just about the recipe it's the stories
behind them why did you want to include
something like that so this has there
eight chapters there's two stories per
chapter about a farmer a harvester a
maker a catcher my friend and
photographer Angie and I drove to 11
States over the course of eight months
to photograph for this book so I really
want to tell the stories of this this
richness and diversity in the south well
I'm gonna have you sign our dish now
yeah if you could have this meal with
anyone past or present who would it be I
would have to say Dolly Parton angel on
this earth yeah Joyce at Dollywood
possibly yes chef Virginia Willis thank
you so thank you so much it's a pleasure
to be here
pleasure to have you for more on chef
Willis and the dish you can head to our
website at CBS this morning calm